[Music]
PlayStation 4 owners are in the enviable
position of having too many great games
to play this year between neo persona 5
near automata and horizon zero dawn to
name a few
there's always something vying for our
attention thus it's easy to see why some
games simply fall through the cracks
though not for lack of appeal we've
rounded up six games from 2017 that we
think deserve a second chance in the
spotlight now if you'd like to see the
games from other consoles that we
thought you missed out on you can
subscribe to the GameSpot YouTube
channel to check those out but for now
let's kick things off with something a
little different imagine a relatively
quiet town in the American Midwest
populated by anthropomorphic animals
that's possum Springs where night in the
woods takes place and as May a cat human
you experience a readjustment to your
hometown after getting the boot from
college this comes in the form of a
side-scrolling adventure where
conversations character interactions and
minigames propel you through a
complicated and emotional tale of modern
young adulthood
every story beat hidden tidbit line of
dialogue and optional interaction
encourages exploring the beautifully
painted world the game isn't for
everyone
but it hits what it aims for through the
uniquely charming artwork of Scott
Benson and the quirky yet emotive
soundtrack from Alec Aloka the poignant
storytelling is wrapped in elements that
elevated above many games this year
next machina effectively channel's the
classic twin-stick shooter web action of
games like Robotron 2084 and smash TV
but that's because Eugene Jarvis the
creator of those games collaborated
alongside the developer housemarque to
create it
next machina is an intense display of
frenetic action that takes the best from
the work of both creative forces
combining it into an exhilarating
experience of non-stop shooting and
dashing if you want to make things even
more hectic you could jump in with a
friend and play cooperatively next
mocking those exhilarating action makes
it well worth your time but be wary the
game is tough so expect your patience
and reflexes to be tested
[Music]
Tokyo 42 is an isometric action game
that blends elements of top-down
shooters with a little stealth in an
open world its story takes you down the
rabbit hole of joining a secret
organization of assassins but it doesn't
take itself too seriously despite the
brutal nature of the firefights and the
unforgiving and sometimes frustrating
bullet-hell like enemy encounters Tokyo
42 still manages to be cute it's
probably the allure of neon signs and
the adorable cats the game is vibrant
and lively on the surface but creepily
sterile and violent as you fight back
against the unjust authority line light
rebels in its simplicity
you control a bright segment along a
long line riddled with obstacles and
puzzles to the tune of a relaxing and
rich soundtrack that seems pulled from a
Disney Pixar film the complexity of the
challenges increases as you trot along
the different stages so you should
expect to sharpen your logic and timing
skills the further you get with line
light you will activate platforms to
connect segments avoid threatening lines
and sometimes guide them towards your
goal by manipulating the path forward
line light feels like a stress ball and
video game form it's tranquil and
soothing but manages to be engaging with
a minimalist presentation
[Music]
what remains of Edith Finch is a game in
the same vein as dear Esther and gone
home that is to say it's a walking
simulator the premise is that the Finch
family carries a supposed curse that
leads every family member to die in
unexpected and bizarre ways it's got a
very final destination II aspect to it
you play as either Finch as you explore
the huge mysterious family Manor to
unearth how members in your family tree
have passed away this opens the door to
a creative flashbacks where you get to
play the last strange moments leading to
people's deaths the story is powerful
gripping and dark like an episode black
mirror it's full of unexpected twists
and turns and could only be effectively
told through a video game considering
you can beat it in under three hours you
should play it as soon as you can Yakuza
zero and body is what made his
predecessors so endearing for fans of
the series effectively combining its
melodrama and seriousness with a dose of
offbeat absurdist comedy while these
extremes don't seem like they'd work
together the game handles a combo with
ease the result is an entertaining
experience that pulls you in with its
involved narrative makes you break into
laughter with its outlandish Schumer and
immerses you in its authentic take on
Japanese culture it's also a prequel to
the entire series so if you've never
tried a Yakuza game before you owe it to
yourself to play Yakuza zero the six
games you've just seen represent a
fraction of the interesting titles that
have hit the ps4 this year you can head
over to GameSpot calm for a more
extensive look at the ps4's hidden gems
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more videos like these covering switch
Xbox one and PC and if you think there's
a game that deserves a bit of extra love
throw it in the comments below